stanley cup finals headed for game two
sadly golden knights aren't in it this
year but if you're still craving some
live hockey action you are in luck
thanks to a brand new professional
hockey league called three ice joining
us to talk more about this great concept
as the ceo of three ice ej johnston
thanks so much for being here it's my
pleasure thank you so this is launching
in las vegas you're taking it on a tour
right that's it so we have nine tour
stops we start here and we finish here
we think vegas is gonna be a long-term
home for us we love this market we love
it as a hockey town we love it as an
entertainment town but yeah we're
kicking off here for father's day the
concept sounds really cool because you
have multiple teams and so essentially
when you go to see this at the orleans
yes you're going to see an entire
tournament unfold in a matter of hours
right right so we've got a bracket style
tournament three opening round games two
semi-finals and a championship so we
crown a winner each time we're there the
whole evening takes place for the course
of three hours and it's just go go go
hair on fire hockey yeah and kind of
like three-on-three basketball caught
fire this is three on three hockey plus
the goalies right that's right so you
have three skaters we call that three on
three even though there's a fourth
player called goalie but yeah for us it
is just a track mate on the ice and we
love it we think we built a better
mousetrap it's great stuff and the
players you got are good players oh yeah
there's a lot of these guys are xnhl
players we've got guys from every league
across the planet ahl nhl echl every
european league these guys they're young
they're fast they got great hands great
wheels and it's just it's a fun time
okay you grew up in pittsburgh right so
you're a penguins guy that's right did
you play a lot of hockey i did i play
roller hockey now i'm probably below
average to average if i'm uh being
generous with myself i think you're
being humble though
my father played hockey for a long time
using the goal uh in the nhl for 16
years with boston bruins toronto maple
leafs and he still works in pittsburgh
penguins now okay so you're a penguins
fan but when your dad played i'm sure
you kind of pulled whatever paycheck was
uh coming in that was the team you
rooted for that was the rule how did you
come up with this concept three on three
yeah the the lightning bulb moment was
um watching the three on three rookie
camps at the pittsburgh penguins and the
new jersey devils and seeing that really
a better version of the game was
emerging the three on three overtime was
probably a year old at this point and
you've got these other snackable leagues
out there big three basketball rugby
sevens formula e the indian premier
league which is a short form version of
cricket and it just coalesced and i said
we've got something here we've got a
better mousetrap it's more exciting than
some of these other sports and it's
built for today's media landscape yeah
the ticket sales are already good
there's a buzz out there you got a good
crowd coming to the orleans when is it
so we are three o'clock local time on
saturday it's a great father's day event
but we're at the orleans arena and fans
can go to 3ice.com buy some tickets and
show up we'd love to have them yeah
still some good seats there sure uh now
okay one of the things people love about
hockey or the fights
do you think they're gonna be any of
those i love i love fights um in our
game we have uh no hitting we like to
say rubbing is racing so you can kind of
lean into some guys but you can't
deliver a pop okay but from a fighting
standpoint no there's no fighting it's a
gentleman's game and we like to focus on
the skill yeah the speed and the goal
scoring and it is going to be fast too
it's going to be real fast somebody
actually threw up during tryouts that's
how fast this game is young guy
this is go go go hockey yes you gotta be
in shape eight minute halves right
that's right running clock two eight
minute halves for a game and then of
course three penalties and that's about
it that's it injuries and penalties and
then we've got three opening round games
two semifinals and a championship it all
takes place in the course of three hours
that's gotta be a blast it's gonna be
fun how many players total are involved
we've got six skaters plus a goalie on
each team so that gives us 42 skaters
and then we've got a taxi squad a
seventh team that we can dip into in
case there's injury
somebody's wife gives birth those kinds
of life events happen but yeah it's 42
starters and then a taxi squad what
other cities are you hitting after las
vegas we're in great hockey markets so
we start and finish in vegas we're in
pittsburgh and nashville for our nhl
cities we're in grand rapids denver
colorado london ontario quebec city
hershey pennsylvania just great great
hockey markets across the uh the country
all right it's called three ice you can
go to threeis.com is that right that's
it all right and look at how cool the
jerseys are so i mean you know right
away you've got it
it's a debut right so this is one of the
team looks right it is it is it's great
i love the concept bj johnston 3ice.com
is the place to go if you want to get
tickets not only for this saturday but
again when you come back in august 20th
august 20th all right best of luck to
you thank you